ونبداها بهذه الحادثه التي وصفت بالاكثر
دمويه منذ عقد من الزمن في الهند حيث
ارتفع عدد ضحايا حادثه تصادم قطاري ركاب
شرق الهند الى
288 قتيلا ونحو 900 مصاب وقد وقع الحادث
بولايه اوديشا وذلك بعد خروج احد القطارين
عن مساره واصطدامه بقطار اخر وقال المدير
العام للجهاز الاطفاء في ولايه اوديشا ان
عمليات الانقاذ مستمره في موقع الحادث
مضيفا ان عدد القتل اخذ في الارتفاع بسبب
كثره الاصابات الخطيره بدوره قال الامين
العام للولايه انه تم ارساله اكثر من 200
سياره اسعاف ومئه طبيب اضافي الى مكان
الحادث للمشاركه في عمليه الانقاذ
انضم الينا من نيودلهي ظفر الاسلام خان
رئيس تحرير صحيفه ميليجازيت سيد خان اذا
ساجعه في الهند غير مسبوقه منذ عقد من
الزمن ما السبب في هذا العدد الكبير من
القتلى حتى الان
التحقيقات الاوليه تقول ان
القطار
المسافرين خرج عن مساره قبل دقائق من
الاستخدام بقطار مدائح
الاستدام الاول كان بين جدار مسافرين
وقطار مدائن ثم جاء في الاداره ثالث وهو
قضاء المسافرين واصطدم بالقدارين
فحدث اصطدام صلاتي في مكان واحد مما ادى
الى الارقام
الى هذه اللحظه هي 300 قتيل
والف جرير وانا اعتقد ان العدد سوف يرتفع
اكثر بكثير من هذا لان القطارات الهنديه
مكتظه جدا
نحن نعرف من المعرفه الشخصيه ان كل قطار
يكون فيه الاف من الناس وخصوصا في الدرجات
التي هي
درجات عامه الناس ستكون مهتزه حتى النهايه
وقيل ان ثلاثه عربات لا تزال لم يتم
انتشال الضحايا منها فاظن ان
عدد القتلى سيكون اكثر بكثير وقال
مسؤول في ولايه اوديسا مسؤول عن عمليات
الانقاذ انه لا يتوقع ان يجد احدا حيا
الان في الانقاذ تم ارسال اكثر من 200
سياره اسعاف ومئه طبيب وهناك حديث عن عدد
كما قلت مرشح للارتفاع بسبب الاصابات
الخطيره كيف تقيم حتى الان تعامل السلطات
الهنديه مع هذه الفاجعه
الهنديه كالعاده قالت ان
سيتم اجراء تحقيق في هذا الحادث
ولا نعرف
نعيد التحقيق اذا كان اداريا او اذا كان
سياسيا فلا فائده منه ولكن تحقيق لو كان
برئاسه قاضي من المحكمه العليا او المحكمه
العاليه فيمكن ان نثق في
عموما هنا
المسؤوليه يعني تناط
بادنى الناس في سلم موظف عادي
مهندس عادي سيتم اعتقاله
يعني الحاق المسؤوليه به بينما وزيره
وهناك الان مطالبات باستقالته ولكن لا
اعتقد انه سيستقيل اخر مره
وزير شقق حديديه استقال كان في زمن نيرو
تقريبا 60 سنه
ما حدث شيء من هذا النوع فاستقال وزير
السجل الغديدي ولكن الان لا نرى هذه
المسؤوليه عموما يعني تنقل الى ادنى الناس
في سلم او ينتهي الامر باعطاء بعض
الاموال للمصابين
للقتلى وقيل ان الحكومه ستصرف تقريبا 50
الف روبيه للمصابين ولا نعرف كم ستصرف
للقتلى وعموما لن تكون اكثر من 3000 او
2000 دولار هكذا هي الحياه هنا في الهند
شكرا لك تصل الاسلام خان رئيس تحرير صحيفه
ملكازيت كنت معنا من نيودلهي